Alright, so let's summarize some of the properties that we've
been talking about just so that they're actually written out. One
is that each iteration as we go through this k-means
process. Each iteration is actually polynomial. It's pretty fast. We just
have to go through and look at the distance between
each center, each of the k centers and each of the
n points, to reassign them. And then we have to run
through all the points to redefine the clusters. There could be
an extra factor of d in here, if these are d dimensional points.
>> Sure.
>> That makes, that makes sense, alright? Then you were just
going through the argument as to why the number of iterations would
be finite and exponential. And the exponential is like k to the
nth. And what you said was the first of the n objects
can be in any of k clusters, and the second can be
in any of the k clusters, and the third can be in
any of the k clusters. So we get a total of k
to the nth different ways of assigning points to the k clusters.
>> But I do think what you said in response to that is
right which is in practice, you're
not going to do an explanation under iteration.
>> Right right, in practice it tends be really,
really quite low. It just kind of clicks into place.
>> Because it's a, it's the same thing for reason why the average is, even
though it's a continuous space, it's still
finite. Distance is a really, really strong concern.
>> Right, and so the error on each iteration is
going to decrease if we break ties consistently. And as you've
been pointing out to me, there is one exception here
whereas if things are assigned to clusters, it could be that
things don't improve, that it stays exactly the same, but that
can only happen once. Because then the clusters are going to get
assigned according to the consistent tie breaking rule, and the next
time through we're going to see that we've converged. But there
is something that we didn't talk about that I think is
important to think through. So here's a set of six points.
>> Okay.
>> If I was going to ask you to make three clusters
of this, what would you do?
>> I would put a and b together, c and d together, and e and f together.
>> Indeed. Alright. So that is the,
that's the optimum here. So, the question is,
write down a way of assigning the three cluster centers to points, so that it
will be stuck there and not get to the, the clustering that you just found.
So, just write down a, b, c, d, e, f. Three of them separated by
commas defining where the centers should start
so that it will actually not make progress.
>> Okay.